mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
madame la rapporteur nous reprenons cet
après-midi les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française par l'audition
de Monsieur Xavier Bertrand sa qualité
d'anciens ministres de la Santé et je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation vous
avez été dans votre carrière
ministérielle chargée de la santé à deux
reprises de juin 2005 à mars 2007 d'une
part en tant que ministre de la Santé et
des Solidarités puis de novembre 2010 à
mai 2012 d'autre part en tant que
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de la
santé
votre expérience est très utile aux
travaux de notre commission d'enquête à
plusieurs titres vous avez d'abord connu
dès 2006 l'apparition
l'apparition et à la vous avez d'abord à
faire face à l'apparition et à la
propagation de la grippe aviaire H5 nain
celle-ci a donné lieu à l'élaboration
notamment d'une doctrine d'emplois et de
stockage des masques en France sur
laquelle une commission d'enquête de
notre assemblée vous a déjà interrogé
vous pourrez sans doute nous faire
partager vos réflexions sur la
constitution de stock stratégique de
médicaments destinés à faire face à une
crise sanitaire de grande ampleur et le
rôle de l'État dans de telles
circonstances puisque entre les stocks
de dispositifs médicaux et les stocks de
médicaments on est vraiment sur la même
logique de pouvoir répondre en urgence à
un besoin qui serait en phase
d'accusation vous avez par ailleurs en
2010 été confronté à la crise du
Médiator auditionnée par la mission
commune d'information mise en place par
le Sénat suite à ce scandale et sur la
base du rapport de l'Inspection générale
des affaires sociales que vous aviez
commandé vous avez à l'époque souligné
l'existence de défaillance grave dans le
fonctionnement de notre système du
médicament
cette crise a modif à motiver un
renforcement important des mesures de
pharmacovigilance et la création par la
loi médicament du 29 décembre 2011 de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé la
NSM en remplacement de l'ancienne agence
française de sécurité sanitaire et des
produits de santé qui ce qu'on nous met
l'afsaps à une scène que nous avons
d'ailleurs déjà auditionnée nous vous
interrogons sur la place de la NSM dans
le paysage des agences sanitaires et son
rôle dans l'anticipation et la gestion
des pénuries de médicaments plus
largement nous souhaitons que vous
puissiez nous faire part de vos
réflexions sur la gouvernance de la
politique du médicament fréquemment
décrite comme
lacunaire ou manquant de pilotage lors
de nos auditions enfin et cela touche
plus directement encore au cœur de nos
travaux vous avez été confrontés dans le
cas de vos fonctions des tensions voir à
des ruptures d'approvisionnement de
certains médicaments à cet écart vous
aviez annoncé dès septembre 2011 la mise
en base d'un plan d'action destiné à
lutter contre ce phénomène en renforçant
les obligations des exploitants comme
des distributeurs et en contraignant les
industriels à mieux anticiper les
risques de pénurie ces axes sont encore
pour l'essentiel ceux qui structurent
les politiques visantes en France à
sécuriser la provisionnement médicaments
progressivement renforcée ces dernières
années les mesures prises n'ont de toute
évidence pas suffi à endiguer
l'aggravation des pénuries nous étions à
environ 700 médicaments en pénurie en
juillet 2018 lorsque lors de la mission
sénatoriale qui a traité de cette
question et nous sommes entre 2500 et
3000 suivants suivant les moments où et
les critères qui sont retenus vous
pourrez dresser le bilan de ce plan
d'action et nous indiquer dans quel
contexte il a été établi plus largement
vous pourrez faire part à la commission
d'enquête de votre analyse sur la
manière d'assurer aux patients l'accès
aux médicaments les plus indispensables
à leur prise en charge
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets monsieur le
ministre votre expérience et votre recul
du fait de vos anciennes fonctions sont
précieux et la commission d'enquête à la
commission d'enquête je vais
immédiatement vous céder la parole pour
un bref propos bref propos introductif
de façon que nous ayez le temps de
pouvoir avoir un échange et des
questions puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapporterait de notre commission
d'enquête vous posera une première série
de questions je précise également que
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et qu'elle
fera l'objet d'un compte rendu publié
avant de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage dans
notre devant notre commission d'enquête
et passive des peines prévues aux
articles 434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code
pénal et je vous invite monsieur le
ministre à prêter serment de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité en levant
la main droite et en disant je le jure
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
peut-être pour un très court propos de
façon à laisser plus de temps si vous le
voulez bien aux échanges j'ai donc
assumé cette fonction à deux reprises
c'est très belle fonction à deux
reprises peut-être en y ajoutant
également la partie de fin mars 2004
jusqu'à juin 2005 où j'étais sous
l'autorité de Philippe bouste Blasi en
charge de l'Assurance maladie non pas en
charge directement de la politique de
santé ou de la politique du médicament
mais sur l'un des éléments concernant
notamment le prix d'un certain nombre de
produits de produits de santé vous
l'avez vous même souligné j'y reviendrai
à l'occasion des questions il est vrai
que en 2011 il y a à la fois le plan
d'action qui est présenté en septembre
2011 et la loi médicament qui a été
adoptée fin décembre 2011 qui ont permis
de changer un certain nombre de choses
concernant justement la disponibilité
des produits de santé la disponibilité
des médicaments mais si j'en viens à ce
qui était la grille de lecture à
l'époque et ce qui est aujourd'hui la
grille de lecture que je me permettrai
de présenter devant de votre commission
d'enquête ça tient trois choses c'est
l'absolu nécessité dans le domaine de la
santé de l'anticipation
nous avons une question clé aujourd'hui
de prix
et nous avons aussi une remise en
question à mon sens de ce que nous
mettons derrière le mot souveraineté
concernant la disponibilité des produits
de santé au-delà même de la question du
prix les pénuries parce que c'est le
réel mot je ne comprends absolument pas
pourquoi il est aujourd'hui une fausse
pudeur gouvernementale à nier la réalité
des faits c'est pas un problème de
tension dans les stocks
d'une insulte professionnelle de santé
aux patients de dire que c'est une
tension des stocks c'est une pénurie et
j'aurais bien aimé qu'au-delà des
différentes déclarations du ministre en
charge de la santé qui nous dit tous les
15 jours qui a pas de pénurie que les
problèmes vont se régler j'aurais bien
aimé la voir avec moi voilà encore deux
semaines dans une pharmacie quand vous
avez besoin d'avoir des médicaments pour
vos enfants c'est sur les médicaments
pédiatriques que le scandale est le plus
patant de bien voir que c'était pas un
problème de tension c'est un problème
tout simplement de pénurie donc un
problème d'anticipation problème de prix
et ensuite une nouvelle définition de ce
que nous mettons derrière le terme de
souveraineté parce que c'est pénurie
vont être amenés à se reproduire
régulièrement et elles vont devenir de
plus en plus vives dans les années qui
viennent on a tout simplement le propos
liminaire que je voulais avoir
très bien c'est parfait merci beaucoup
je passe ta parole à Laurence Cohen
rapporteur pour une première série de
questions
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
propos extrêmement
court mais en même temps très
synthétique et qui met vraiment les
projecteurs sur les problèmes réels tels
que tel qu'ils se présente alors
effectivement
vous avez vous avez raison de souligner
que là nous sommes face à des pénuries
et malheureusement
ces pénuries ne font que se multiplier
c'est-à-dire au fur et à mesure il y a
de plus en plus de médicaments qui sont
touchés et les médicaments qui ont été
particulièrement touchés c'est
effectivement les médicaments à usage
pédiatrique qui ont été très touchées
moi j'aimerais donc que vous puissiez
approfondir un certain nombre d'éléments
quand en 2011 vous avez donc annoncé un
plan d'action pour justement lutter
contre les ruptures de stock de
médicaments la situation n'était pas la
même en 2011 bien évidemment aujourd'hui
mais je voudrais savoir comment les
acteurs de la chaîne du médicament
avait-il réagi à ses propositions et
avec le recul que vous pouvez avoir
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que ces mesures
étaient suffisantes et comment
aujourd'hui on peut modifier les choses
pour dépasser les problèmes que nous
vivons ça c'est ma première ma première
question ma deuxième question concerne
effectivement ce cas souligné la
présidente concernant votre action quant
à la création de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament
est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui qu'il
est pertinent de confier à cette agence
la surveillance et la gestion des des
ruptures de stock de médicaments et
est-ce que vous pensez également que
cette agence dispose de moyens
financiers humains suffisants ce qu'on a
pu constater lors de des auditions des
différentes agences
c'est qu'on leur demande de plus en plus
de responsabilités de plus en plus de
missions mais j'allais dire en fait à
moyen constant ce qui est ce qui est
quand même un peu plus compliqué
la troisième la troisième question là
encore c'est que c'est venu très
fortement dans les différentes auditions
si le problème de gouvernance et de
pilotage de l'ensemble de la politique
du médicament
de manière familière où il y a un
certain nombre d'auditionnés qui nous
ont dit qu'en fait ils se demandaient
s'il y avait un pilote dans l'avion pour
le dire de manière familière donc
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait mettre justement en
oeuvre pour remédier à ce problème
ma quatrième question ça concerne
l'engagement du du gouvernement
aujourd'hui de relocaliser les
médicaments et les principes actifs
effectivement c'est une politique qui
date depuis 30 ans où il y a eu une des
délocalisations extrêmement importantes
délocalisations d'ailleurs qui était
voulu parce que
il semblait beaucoup plus rentable
d'installer les industries en Asie
notamment où en Inde avec une exigence
des critères environnementaux et sociaux
moindres aujourd'hui on revient sur
cette sur cette sur ces données et sur
cette politique plus exactement et on
parle de relocalisation relocalisation
il faut il faut raisons garder on va pas
relocaliser en France toutes les
médicaments il faut qu'il y ait une
harmonisation en bonne int intelligence
pour le moins avec avec
l'Europe et je voudrais savoir parce que
vous avez votre expérience de ministre
notamment mais vous êtes vous êtes élu
d'une région irresponsable d'une région
industrielle et dans laquelle il y a
plusieurs sites de fabrication
très importants et je pense à Sanofi
mais il y a d'autres je vais pas toutes
les citer parce qu'elles sont elles sont
nombreuses donc à votre avis comment
est-ce qu'il faut procéder pour qu'il y
ait de réels relocalisation est-ce que
finalement
il ne faut pas prendre en compte le fait
que à partir du moment où il y a une
relocalisation en France et en Europe et
bien il faut prendre en compte donc
cette relocalisation y compris dans le
prix du médicament parce que sinon on va
entraîner une concurrence qui va pas
être équitable si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi et est-ce que vous pensez parce
que là encore quand j'ai parlé de
critères environnementaux c'est que tout
le monde se dit aujourd'hui ou beaucoup
la majorité se disent aujourd'hui oui il
faut relocaliser mais en même temps si
on a délocalisé l'industrie chimique
c'est qu'elle était polluante donc
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est prêt
quand je dis on est prêt c'est
collectivement parce qu'un élu qui dit
voilà je vais rapatrier dans ma région
il peut aussi avoir une levée de
bouclier en disant mais pas pas ici pas
chez nous donc est-ce qu'on est en
mesure aujourd'hui de maîtriser
l'empreinte environnementale de de ces
relocalisations
et puis je voudrais vous vous interroger
de manière toujours dans le même ordre
d'idées de manière peut-être un peu plus
précise parce que la semaine dernière
nous avons rencontré le PDG du groupe
Atlantis qui a indiqué donc la
liquidation judiciaire de l'usine
syntaxime de Calais et
il a il a il a signifié qu'il pour lui
il était impossible de relocaliser en
France la production de molécules à très
gros volume et à faible valeur ajoutée
donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de ce
constat et comment dans ce cas sécuriser
l'approvisionnement de la France et de
l'Europe en médicament mature qui sont
fréquemment utilisés par par les
Français enfin ma toute dernière
question c'est peut-être encore plus
précisément sur le prix j'ai donné un
indice si je puis dire en disant qu'il
fallait prendre en compte la
relocalisation en France et et en Europe
mais au cours de nos de nos auditions la
question du prix est revenue fortement
je ne veux pas simplifier la donne comme
aucun d'ailleurs de mes collègues autour
de cette table les pénuries c'est
multifactoriels et il y a pas qu'une
solution ça serait ça serait trop facile
mais par rapport à ce prix vous avez
déclaré me semble-t-il assez récemment
que il fallait payer les médicaments
plus chers qu'aujourd'hui je pense que
vous faisiez allusion évidemment enfin
aux médicaments matures mais je veux pas
transformer vos propos mais ça me semble
évident mais on a constaté que dans
d'autres pays où les prix des
médicaments est beaucoup plus onéreux je
pense notamment à la Suisse il souffrait
des mêmes pénuries et notamment au
niveau des au niveau des antibiotiques
donc on voit bien là que les choses ne
sont pas si simple que ça et du coup je
fais un lien avec l'ONDAM
qui est consacrée aux médicaments et qui
sert quand même de variables
d'ajustement aux réductions de budget de
la santé d'une manière générale et que
peut-être là on est allé aussi trop loin
dans la faiblesse de cette de cette
enveloppe en jouant jouer n'est pas le
mot exact mais
en faisant un espèce d'équilibre entre
les produits innovants dont les prix
s'envolent et les produits matures dans
les prix sont bas voilà les les six
questions que je voulais vous poser
monsieur le ministre vous voyez que du
coup je balaye beaucoup de points
on vous remercie infiniment de vos
propos exactement
tout à l'heure vous permettez de les
prendre à l'envers de façon à ce que la
mémoire soit plus fraîche sur la
question de la dame oui vous avez raison
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai indiqué
à l'un de son souvenir pardon le
sénateur Milon s'en souvient
certainement lors de l'examen du dernier
PLFSS qui précédait l'élection
présidentielle et d'ailleurs je vais
reprendre exactement j'ai pas retrouvé
les termes exact de ma déclaration mais
les termes de utilisés par Nora Berra
qui était ma secrétaire d'État chargée
de la Santé qui est me représenter au
banc de l'Assemblée nationale lors de
l'examen du PLFSS 2012 le 27 octobre
2011 j'ai pas retrouvé les minutes du
Sénat disait la chose suivante mon nom
c'est mon temps
d'économie demandait aux médicaments ces
montants doivent rester compatibles avec
le développement d'une industrie à force
d'investissement il s'agit d'un enjeu
essentiel tout démarche à un début mais
aussi une fin des prélèvements d'un
montant total de 1,26 milliards d'euros
sont déjà assez substantiels car il faut
laisser l'industrie pharmaceutique
l'opportunité d'investir dans les
produits de santé qui seront utiles à la
prise en charge des patients à l'avenir
de façon moins protocolaire j'ai
toujours eu coutume de dire que j'avais
demandé beaucoup d'efforts à l'industrie
du médicament beaucoup parce que j'ai
été en charge à partir de 2004 une
réforme de l'assurance maladie qui
visait à sauvegarder notre système de
santé l'assurance maladie j'avais
indiqué qu'on était certainement allé
jusqu'à l'os et que nous ne pouvions pas
demander des forces supplémentaires dans
les 10 ans qui sont écoulés des efforts
supplémentaires ont été demandés et
après on s'étonne du résultat je le dis
très clairement ici à la tribune du
Sénat
dans un PLFSS mémorable où il avait été
question le sénateur bilan s'en souvient
d'autres débats opticiens optométriques
et autres mais on était sur cette
question là à l'époque j'avais demandé
beaucoup d'efforts et j'ai dit on ne
pourra pas continuer à ce rythme là on a
continué à ce rythme là et on a même
accentué le rythme c'est pas un propos
comment dirais-je secret je tiens il est
à la tribune du Sénat et Nora Beral fait
à l'Assemblée nationale donc on peut pas
continuer après s'étonner alors c'est
vrai que l'on dit où il y a des
médicaments nouveaux qui sont très chers
oui mais les médicaments mature on en a
besoin également et est-ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est que les médicaments qui
aujourd'hui posent des problèmes de
disponibilité sont des médicaments qui
sont issus de la chimie à proprement
parler or ce sont ceux-là qui ont fait
l'objet des délocalisations importantes
sauf que c'est pas seulement les
nouveaux traitements dont on a besoin ce
sont aussi les autres donc il y a cette
question de London qui couvre clairement
et je répondrai aussi en partie aux
autres questions que vous posez
notamment à la cinquième question sur
saint-exil quel est le problème qu'il y
a il le dit très clairement vu le prix
qui est payé il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
d'intérêt forcément un relocaliser et
puis il y a aussi un autre sujet si je
ne me trompe pas qu'il avance parce que
nous l'avons aidé nous au niveau de la
région à un moment donné c'est que tout
le problème de l'industrie du médicament
c'est aussi ce qu'il y a comme nouveau
médicament dans les pipes or là comme il
n'y avait rien qui était dans les
pailles qui un jour allait arriver en
production il savait pertinemment que
les perspectives risquaient d'être fatal
donc prix et paille c'est ça qui a fait
justement défaut à saint-exibles mais si
on en revient clairement la question du
prix qui est quand même le cœur du
problème
il y a que Sanofi sont les seuls tout le
reste est parti si vous voulez avoir le
mouvement en sens inverse il faut qu'il
y ait une politique de prix qui soit
élaborée par le CEPS mais je vais
revenir avec le feu vert de Bercy qui
permet justement de mieux valoriser la
rémunération de ces labos qui seront des
entreprises on va dire européenne qui
sont des entreprises françaises avec un
prix qui vient cibler le retour
justement de ces médicaments sur le
territoire national si c'est une mesure
large ça ne fonctionnera pas si c'est
une mesure large pour que les grands
labos reviennent à cela c'est pas
justement ce qu'ils ont en tête et donc
ça doit être très clairement ciblé mais
là madame la rapporteur se pose une
question qui fixe le prix des
médicaments en France
ce que la dichotomie insupportable entre
le ministère de la santé et le ministère
de l'économie des finances et du budget
c'est le fond du problème c'est le fond
du problème j'ai toujours connu ça dans
une vie antérieure ou bien évidemment
c'est dur vous faites le PLFSS mais
aujourd'hui avec la logique des comptes
publics la politique du médicament comme
une bonne partie de la politique de
santé et encore je vais pas parler
d'autres politiques elle est faite à
Bercy avec des raisonnements comptables
donc de court terme comment voulez-vous
avoir une logique d'investissement alors
si parfois vous avez le ministère de
l'Économie et des Finances qui dit que
sur vocation très stratégique des choses
on doit investir oui mais c'est le
contraire qui se fait chaque année et
donc tant qu'on n'a pas une unité une
unité d'actions de définition de la
stratégie et pardonnez-moi de le dire
qui doit être fixé par le ministère de
la Santé ça ne peut pas marcher ça ne
peut pas marcher parce que bien souvent
la santé le médicament je crois encore
une fois la variable d'ajustement
comment voulez-vous bâtir quelque chose
au-delà des grands discours
donc vous ne pouvez pas avoir le CEPS
d'un côté et les influences qui sont
celles de Bercy sans qu'on aboutisse à
des situations comme celle-ci c'est ça
le fond du problème donc très très
clairement sur la relocalisation je vous
le dis on a très clairement ce besoin de
cibler une politique de prix sur ce type
de médicament là pas surtout pas surtout
pas surtout les produits qui soient une
mesure et il faut aussi l'assumer les
Allemands de se gêne pas pour le faire
qui puissent profiter vraiment à nos PME
celle qui accepteront le consentir
l'effort d'investissement et ensuite
d'avoir accès à un remboursement qui
leur donne une vraie visibilité ce que
vous pouvez favoriser l'investissement
que vous voulez si derrière il y a pas
une seule mobilisation du marché ça ne
peut pas fonctionner et dans ces cas-là
vous avez quelque chose qui peut tient
la route et répondre justement au défi
ceci ne nous dispensant pas d'une
véritable politique européenne en la
matière parce que vous avez raison de le
souligner
les pénuries touchent l'ensemble des
pays d'Europe et ça ne s'arrêtera pas
parce que aujourd'hui nous avons une
dépendance à l'un des Lachine ok ce qui
nous pendait c'est la dépendance aux
États-Unis dans les années qui viennent
non pas forcément seulement là où
médicament mature mais sur les nouvelles
thérapies parce que c'est ça le problème
de demain les pénuries ne s'arrangeront
pas mais là c'est les États-Unis qui
vont pouvoir dicter le la en matière de
disponibilité sur le marché mondial donc
on peut très bien regarder l'Asie et
l'Inde mais il faut aussi qu'on regarde
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique là où on
a besoin d'une politique européenne
c'est aussi pour qu'on établisse d'une
certaine façon une liste de médicaments
stratégiques aussi au niveau européen
faut de quoi on tombera dans les mêmes
problèmes le seul point sur lequel je
suis pas en divergence avec vous mais
pour bien préciser ma position
il faut bien voir une chose c'est que si
je ne me trompe pas la France est leader
en termes de production de médicaments
en Europe grosso modo de 1995 à 2008
2010 je crois que c'est 2008 aujourd'hui
on est devenu le quatrième producteur de
médicaments en Europe après Suisse
Allemagne - Italie et quatrième
producteur en Europe ça doit faire de
nous le 5e encore que moi je pensais
qu'on était plus loin que cela le
cinquième au niveau mondial bon sauf que
c'était en début d'année le LEM a
produit une étude comparative nos
médicaments globalement sont 40% moins
cher qu'en Suisse ils sont 33% moins
cher qu'en Allemagne et ils sont 18%
moins cher qu'en Italie je parle pas de
la Grande-Bretagne qui n'est plus dans
l'Union européenne ok qu'est-ce qui se
passe nous avons un nombre de labos qui
ne sont pas par nature des philanthropes
ok bah où est-ce qu'ils mettent leur
médicament priorité là où c'est le plus
rémunérateur pour eux alors je sais bien
que quand on va chez le pharmacien
ne regarde plus le prix le prix des le
prix des médicaments mais quand on les
regarde bien j'ai été confronté moi sur
la disponibilité de médicaments
pédiatriques en fin d'année mais c'est
de la folie qu'on voyait le prix de
l'amoxicilline quand il prit du
doliprane quand il prit du doliprane
liquide pour les enfants on est en
dessous de 2 euros 50 et après on
s'étonne que ces produits ces produits
soient cheminés en priorité dans des
pays qui les rémunère mieux ça résume
pas tout vous avant entièrement raison
c'est multifactoriel c'est vrai mais
quand même il y a un aspect nous sommes
devenus trop peu cher par rapport à
d'autres pays et ses laboratoires bien
évidemment les mettre sur les marchés
qui sont plus rémunérateurs on est allé
au-delà de l'os en la matière et c'est
ça aujourd'hui qui est arrivé et quand
je vous parle de cette déclaration que
je fais elle a maintenant 11 ans et demi
elle a pas 11 mois et demi elle a très
clairement 11 ans 11 ans et demi donc
voilà pourquoi j'en suis intimement
convaincu il nous faut aujourd'hui
rétablir une nouvelle politique de prix
et de cibler des questions de
rémunération des laboratoires en
fonction des médicaments qu'on aura
estimé comme stratégique et surtout en
fonction du profil des entreprises qui
sont nature à accueillir justement ces
relocalisations alors vous parlez de la
question environnementale très
franchement aujourd'hui je le vois avec
nombre d'industries que nous accueillons
dans la région des Hauts de France on
est capable
de pouvoir montrer que ce soit sur les
émanations ou autres on est capable de
prendre l'ensemble des filtrages
possibles l'ensemble des mesures
protectrices de l'environnement et s'il
y a des préventions nous savons
pertinemment que les enquêtes publiques
et ceux qui nous est demandé au niveau
environnemental ne permet plus de faire
les erreurs qui auraient pu être
commises dans les années 60 et 70 et je
le vois notamment sur des extensions
vous avez parlé dans la région de Sanofi
mais je pense notamment GSK à
Saint-Amand à strazaneca sur le
Dunkerquois ça ne pose aucun problème
avec les riverains que de voir des
extensions de sites industriels
pharmaceutiques loin sans faux vous
m'avez aussi parlé de la question des
mesures qui avaient été prises et ce
qu'elles avaient été acceptées alors il
y a deux choses il y a les mesures que
je suis amenées à élaborer parce que
la société française a essayé de
réanimation m'alertent à l'été 2011 sur
la question et le 2 août de Milo est
aussi des associations de patients à
l'époque des associations de patients on
est en amont parce qu'on sur la question
de l'anesthésie de la rédémie
au cœur de la crise covid on a eu un
problème d'alimentation curare on a
failli avoir un vrai problème de
disponibilité durable sur le cura nul
besoin de vous expliquer ici le côté
absolument indispensable du curare pour
pour la réa les problèmes sont encore
devant nous les problèmes sont encore
devant nous sur la seule question du
plus rare donc à la question l'alerte
vient la société française et les
associations de patients donc moi je le
dis aussi très clairement à l'époque je
dans les médias je dénonce un système
d'importation qui prive les pharmaciens
français d'approvisionnement se sont mes
termes et je me dis prêt à contraindre
l'élaboratoires à respecter leurs
engagements là-dessus j'avais fait
procéder en mars 2011 à des enquêtes et
j'avais mobilisé c'était pas de mon
ressort la DGCCRF sur cette question là
à la suite de la réunion avec l'ensemble
des acteurs le 8 septembre 2011 à
l'époque j'annonce excusez-moi de lire
parce que c'est quand même la 12 ans
donc j'ai un peu vieilli de vieilli
depuis je me souviens plus précisément
on annonce un plan d'action qui est mis
en oeuvre sans délai sans délais c'est
pas pour dans 6 mois sans délai sous
l'égide de la DGS et de la SAPS mais la
DGS je ne délègue pas à la sable ce soin
de tout mettre qui pose d'ailleurs les
questions de gouvernance je vais revenir
dans un instant un on rappelle les
obligations de service public de chacun
des acteurs avec des contrôles on
identifie les zones de risque avec une
liste de classe thérapeutiques définies
à l'époque comme sensible c'est-à-dire
présentant à la fois un intérêt majeur
mais aussi avec un risque de rupture
notamment avec ces questions
d'approvisionnement et la mise en place
d'un suivi national des
approvisionnements de ces produits on
était si je me trompe pas à l'époque sur
les entiers rétroviraux sur les
anesthésiques et on était aussi sur les
anticancéreux je crois que ça doit être
ça on avait un plan de gestion des
pénuries à la charge des titulaires
d'AMM et on avait mis aussi en place un
circuit d'information rapide pour
permettre de signaler toute rupture de
stock potentiel pas seulement avérée
mais aussi potentiel on s'était même
penché sur la question des AR êtes
commercialisation vous savez quand un
labo décide de ne plus commercialiser un
produit comment on fait pour que les
personnes directement concernées et les
prescripteurs puissent mieux s'organiser
et ne pas se retrouver qu'un système de
défaillance justement de traitement ça
ça va plutôt bien bon ma loi dite du 29
décembre 2011 avait recueilli un très
très large un sentiment sur les bancs du
Sénat et de l'assemblée
c'était pas tout à fait la même chose
dans le monde pharmaceutique parce que
la loi du médicament imposait des
changements drastiques notamment sur la
question des conflits d'intérêt sur la
question d'intervention du monde
pharmaceutique
dans le financement du monde de la santé
mais là ce qui avait été établi sur
cette partie là ça savait poser moins de
difficultés c'est qu'il y avait toute
une partie un dispositif réglementaire
sur la prévention de la gestion des
ruptures de stock et d'approvisionnement
pas seulement de stock mais aussi
l'approvisionnement le délai
d'information de la NSM auquel est tenue
d'exploiter tenue l'exploitant avant de
suspendre d'arrêter la commercialisation
a été étendue six mois avant à un an
avant parce qu'à l'époque c'était ça qui
nous a inquiétait il y avait un système
d'astreinte pour les grossistes
répartisseurs et il y avait aussi des
obligations de services publics
nouvelles qui avaient été créés pour les
grossistes répartiteurs et en plus tout
manquement à tout cela engageait des
sanctions financières assez assez
importantes donc voilà ce été mis en
place après il y a un sujet vous savez
c'est pas tout à fait nouveau quand
administra arrive toujours un peu
compliqué de reprendre à son compte et à
100% ce qu'un autre ministre a fait on
l'a vu sur des décrets d'application qui
devait encore être publiées et cela fait
maintenant je dirais pas de bêtises 11
ans après
je n'ai pas suivi à la lettre ce qui
s'est passé ensuite mais le problème est
simple je le dis souvent une loi votée
c'est bien une loi appliquée c'est mieux
et après se pose un autre problème que
vous avez pointé du doigt madame la
rapporteur
c'est que qui pilote il y a un mal
français c'est que on a éloigné du
centre de décision politique les centres
d'action et contrôle c'est la question
des agences alors il faut savoir quelle
est la jeunesse de cette agence de ces
agences c'est d'ailleurs l'un des points
sur lesquels quand il a crise du
médicament j'avais voulu revenir je
pense que la responsabilité politique ne
se délègue pas ne se partage pas elle
appartient propre au ministre et que
même si le ministre ne peut peut-être
pas tout voir et autres il doit
organiser son action de façon à ce que
la responsabilité politique ne soit pas
éloignée du ministère c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous ne pouvez pas
déléguer à la seule agence le soin de
faire les choses il faut que ce soit le
ministère pas forcément le cabinet du
mini surtout aujourd'hui avec les
contraintes d'effectives dans les
cabinets mais tout simplement que ce
soit le ministère que ce soit les
directions du ministère qui soit tenues
de suivre les choses et de ne pas dire
c'est pas moi ce sont les agences bon
maintenant pas non plus raconter
l'histoire c'est aussi la vision que
j'ai tout ça relève de la presse en
contaminée la responsabilité
ministérielle ayant été fortement
engagée il y a eu tout un souci dans les
années 90 pour éloigner niveau de
responsabilité de déléguer des agences
cet appareil on est allé trop loin
là-dedans parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas qu'il n'y ait aucune
responsabilité et à les politiques et la
question de la disponibilité des
médicaments relève de l'essence de la
politique de l'anticipation et de la
prise en charge de l'état de santé nos
concitoyens et encore une fois il s'agit
pas de dessaisir la NSA mais il s'agit
tout simplement qu'il y ait une
véritable surveillance à l'époque qui
avait été mise en place notamment sur la
loi médicament c'est que la liste des
médicaments qui pouvait poser problème
cette liste là ce soit le ministre qui
est régulièrement et à se prononcer
dessus ou que ce soit en sa présence de
façon encore une fois à ne pas éloigner
le centre de décision c'est ça dont on
souffre aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne comprennent
pas un qu'on soit dans le déni non non
il y a pas de pénurie ou alors si on a
un léger problème de rupture de stock
vous inquiétez pas dans 15 jours c'est
réglé c'est plutôt tous les 15 jours
qu'on a les mêmes déclarations plutôt
qu'on a les solutions et c'est ça qui
pose aujourd'hui le véritable le
véritable problème donc voilà un peu le
regard que j'ai donc est-ce qu'il faut
enlever à la NSM non mais pas la seule à
NSM le contrôle doit être politique et
politique c'est le ministère encore une
fois pas le seul cabinet mais le
ministère
j'ai peut-être pas répondu à tout mais
dans ces cas-là vous vous n'hésiterez
pas à me à me réinterroger mais j'ai
essayé de prendre effectivement à la
volée vos remarques et vos questions
merci beaucoup donc je vais pas passer
la parole au collège
merci monsieur le ministre de l'ensemble
de ses propos auxquels j'adhère
complètement je voudrais revenir sur sur
un des points que vous avez abordé c'est
celui de l'effort demandait à
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est un
effort qui est considérable et c'est
surtout un effort qui est inconstant
d'une année sur l'autre les efforts sont
différents ce qui fait que les
entreprises internationales nationales
ne peuvent pas faire de prévisions
budgétaire sauf à la fin de l'année et
parfois les directeurs nationaux sont
obligés d'être dire à leur directeur
internationaux on me demande par un
milliard cette année mais 700 millions
et après on me demande pas un milliard
mais un milliard 8 et ça l'inconstance
crée des problèmes majeurs au niveau de
l'industrie pharmaceutique je voudrais
revenir sur la composition du CEPS aussi
je crois qu'il est en effet important et
je vous rejoins complètement ça m'embête
de dire vous mais là on est en officiel
donc elle vous rejoins complètement
il faudrait que dans le CEPS le
ministère de la santé soit dominant
alors pour l'instant c'est Bercy qui est
dominant dans la composition de la
composition des fonctionnaires
représentant les ministériales la
recherche l'industrie les le budget
l'économie le budget ou l'économie et la
santé et la santé c'est le nombre de
fonctionnaires le moins important à
l'intérieur du CEPS donc il est
important que le CEPS voit sa
recomposition faite au profit de la
santé et je crois que sur ce sujet je
vous rejoins complètement j'ai une
petite question
lorsque l'agence européenne donne un
avis positif sur un nouveau médicament
est-il
utile que la NSM l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament françaises reçoit
toutes les études afin de dire si ce
médicament est acceptable ou pas et
qu'ensuite après la NSM la HAS elle-même
disent peut-être que oui peut-être que
non
on perd un temps fou par rapport à
d'autres pays par rapport à l'Allemagne
par rapport à la Belgique est-ce que
c'est vraiment utile que les avis de
agence européenne soit reconsidérées par
des agences nationales
de poser une question à un sénateur qui
vient de poser une question
la parour est tout à fait répondre par
une question si vous le souhaitez même
si ça nous empêchera pas d'exiger une
réponse à un moment Laurence Harris s'il
vous plaît
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre est revenu sur deux trois
petites choses que vous avez dites pour
avoir un éclairage supplémentaire
vous vous plaidez finalement pour une
revalorisation de du prix du médicament
en particulier les médicaments matures
d'autant plus que
vous soulignez que ça profiterait au PME
et c'est quelque chose qui ressort de
nos auditions où on sent bien finalement
qu'on est passé d'un marché de masse à
un marché de niche et que de fait
l'industrie pharmaceutique est en train
de s'organiser sur ces deux types de
marchés donc on vous suivrait assez
facilement mais la préoccupation c'est
de vérifier que c'est effectivement
les PME qui vont en bénéficier sachant
que l'industrie pharmaceutique est très
fragmenté et que si on prend un exemple
peut-être que je me trompe mais comme
biogaran qui est dans le top 10 des
médicaments génériques et des l'une des
premières entreprises françaises et
qu'on pourrait considérer finalement
comme quelqu'un qui pourrait être
accompagné dans cette production là
c'est quand même une filiale de Servier
donc il y a un moment donné on sent bien
que les équilibres sont pas garanties
donc qu'est-ce qui pourrait garantir ça
parce que en même temps on a bien le
sentiment qu'on est à la charnière de
quelque chose et qu'on a une
modification en profondeur de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et puis la
deuxième question parce que je veux pas
monopoliser et d'autres ont certainement
des questions vous parlez d'obligation
de service public on l'a abordé ce matin
avec avec une autre ministre qui vous a
succédé
c'est bien les obligations de services
publics mais quels sont les moyens de
contrôle et de sanctions et dans votre
expérience même si vous vous avez
finalement innové dans la dans les dans
les procédures et dans la dans cette
vision là peut-être que le recul est pas
assez nécessaire pour savoir comment ça
peut être contrôlé mais en tout cas
comment nous on pourrait faire des
propositions pour garantir cette cet
élément là merci Pascal Grigny
même la présidente monsieur le ministre
j'ai juste complété une chose dont on
parle pas c'est la consommation des
médicaments en France parce que la
pénurie bien sûr elle est partout elle
est plus importante chez nous et quand
on va les consommations d'allemand
d'antibiotiques de psychotropes etc elle
est plus forte en France est-ce que vous
avez un regard sur sur ça
sur sur le les prix du médicament bien
entendu ça c'est vraiment le sujet qui
ressort beaucoup en revanche il y a le
budget de la Sécurité sociale vous avez
parlé de Bercy mais le budget de la
Sécurité sociale qui est quand même est
toujours déficitaire qu'on a du mal à
équilibrer et qui est encore en visuel
je veux dire on va chercher
dans d'autres budgets pour essayer de
compenser donc c'est vraiment un souci
donc quelle solution quelle solution
et qui doit fin Ancer les stocks
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est c'est
l'entreprise qui doit financer le stock
c'est une des questions que nous sommes
posées avec Laurence harribet parce
qu'on est sur l'Europe du médicament
commission des affaires européennes
parce que le stocks ça coûte cher en
fait si on l'impose aux entreprises et
comme vous avez dit en plus j'ai bien
retenu que finalement on leur avait déjà
demandé beaucoup si on leur demande en
plus ça voilà merci
Emilienne Pomerol
oui merci le président de mon aussi
Monsieur le Ministre parler du prix
puisque on sent bien au fil des
auditions que c'est un des problèmes
majeurs et interroger un petit peu sur
la transparence des prix du médicament
on a questionné à plusieurs reprises les
différentes
institutions et les labos on a pu
rencontrer on a du mal à savoir quel est
le prix de revient comment il est pris
en compte comment est pris en compte
éventuellement la recherche et
développement et en particulier la
recherche fondamentale et la recherche
publique qui participent à ce prix et si
je suis d'accord avec vous pour dire que
effectivement merci à une place
certainement beaucoup trop importante
par rapport au ministère de la Santé
comment on peut mieux
j'allais dire donner des critères sur
l'établissement des prix et je pense
vous avez beaucoup parlé des prix des
médicaments matures qui effectivement
ont été rongeront j'ai rangé mais
quid du prix comment fixe-t-on
aujourd'hui le prix de ce médicament
innovants les biothérapies
thérapiegéniques qui atteignent des
sommes exorbitantes comment on peut les
justifier comment on peut les contrôler
oui moi j'ajouterai à cette question
budgétaire le fait que quand on a
auditionné
la CNAM
il y a trois axes que qui sont qui
sous-tendent les choix stratégiques de
la CNAM et dans les trois axes il y a la
soutenabilité donc la dimension
budgétaire est mise quasiment au même
niveau que la dimension sanitaire et que
on parle beaucoup de Bercy mais en
réalité c'est à toutes les échelles et
notamment en matière de politique du
médicament que c'est considération
budgétaire se décline et donc est-ce
qu'il y a pas aussi de ce point de vue à
réfléchir sur les orientations et
peut-être cette idée un peu un peu
comment dire permanente que nous avons
de plusieurs années de trivialement
comme on dit boucher le trou de la Sécu
alors qu'en réalité on est bien dans des
politiques de santé publique et que on
doit déborder ce cadre là voilà je vous
remercie
je vous laisse prendre
la transparence du prix du médicament va
ce sujet parce que derrière vous avez
toujours le secret des affaires je ne
sais pas comment les choses se passent
encore aujourd'hui moi j'ai connu dans
mes fonctions ministérielles notamment
un grand patron du CEPS qui était Noël
Renaudin et qui rentrait à chaque fois
dans des vrais discussions négociations
avec les labos il y avait besoin de
savoir ça il y avait la question des
prix pratiqués dans d'autres pays en
Europe et ça renvoie aussi à la question
que vous évoquiez la question de la
lisibilité de la visibilité quand on
était aussi à avoir des discussions en
la matière beaucoup de centres de
décision qu'il n'était pas en France
pour des laboratoires étrangers nous
disait la France marché est important
dépense de santé se situe un niveau
important du PIB mais c'est impossible
d'avoir des prévisions parce qu'en
fonction de tel ou tel amendement même
gouvernemental dans un PLFSS toute notre
stratégie d'investissement
d'industrialisation peut être remise en
cause et on a les pires difficultés avec
vous en France avoir une vision même pas
de long terme mais une vision de moyen
terme donc et se poser aussi la question
en France comme il n'y a pas de
politique également de moyens et long
terme et comme nous voulions avoir accès
aux médicaments les plus innovants c'est
quand même un peu moins le cas
aujourd'hui on n'a pas forcément la
garantie d'avoir tout de suite les
médicaments les plus innovants c'était
ça la difficulté donc il y a une partie
de secret des affaires mais il y a une
partie avec des vrais professionnels
d'avoir un regard sur ce qui correspond
prix et vous sentez aussi dans une
négociation ce quel point de rupture ou
ce qui n'est pas le point de rupture
tout ce que je vous dis là remonte
maintenant à plus de 15 années je ne
sais pas exactement comment les choses
se font aujourd'hui mais ce que je sais
c'est que quand on a un regard purement
budgétaire ça peut pas réussir ça c'est
sûr et certain alors attendez je vous
dis ça j'ai quand même eu à conduire au
départ sur l'autorité de Philippe
dousseau Blazy et ensuite dans ma
responsabilité ministériale a conduit
une réforme de l'assurance maladie sur
laquelle personne n'aurait parié un
centime d'euro à l'époque sur ce
résultat elle a produit plus de
résultats d'économies qu'il n'y en avait
au départ dans les objectifs de la
réforme parce qu'encore une fois une loi
voté c'est bien il doit appliquer c'est
mieux une réforme engagée c'est bien une
réforme suivie des faits c'est mieux et
donc nous avions réussi justement à le
faire donc je sais que dans la vie il
faut savoir compter surtout quand on est
responsable public mais encore une fois
pas en oubliant les impératifs Swan
investissement soit les impératifs de
santé publique et ça nous renvoie aussi
à une autre à une autre question que
posait la sénatrice Pascal gruni je
souris parce que
c'est la triste parce la vie présidente
la vice-présidente du Sénat Pascal
Grigny c'est que tout ça nous conduit à
quel modernisation du système de santé
je pense que aujourd'hui vous voyez dans
nos services publics il va y avoir des
investissements importants à faire il y
a peut-être des services publics sur
lesquels c'est pas une question de
moyens supplémentaires sur la santé on
échappera pas la question des moyens
supplémentaires c'est pas là on peut se
raconter tout ce que l'on veut ça sera
pas possible pourquoi parce qu'il y aura
la question des thérapies innovantes qui
coûtent de plus en plus cher et un pays
comme la France ne peut pas voir dans
d'autres pays les médicaments innovants
sur le marché et les plus riches d'entre
nous être capable de les acheter sur
Internet ou à l'étranger pendant que les
autres qui auront pas accès et ça va
continuer et l'autre part nous savons
pertinemment que les investissements
dans les personnels vont rester une
priorité au-delà des Ségur au delà des
Ségur alors bien sûr qu'il y a des
économies c'est la triste c'est
notamment sur la question des actes
redondants les actes redondants donc
toujours pas baissé à l'époque déjà on
parlait d'un milliard et demi d'euros
bon ils sont effectués ils sont
pratiqués ils sont pas des faux-acts
mais ce qui peut aussi la question de la
pertinence des actes déjà d'un point de
vue médical et ensuite au niveau du coût
de la sécurité sociale mais même s'il y
a des gisements d'économie ça n'est pas
à des besoins en financement dans le
système de santé dans les années qui
viennent c'est le service public qui
aujourd'hui a le besoin le plus
d'engager d'engager des moyens donc nous
n'y échas nous n'y échapperons pas la
question c'est de savoir sur quoi on met
les priorités et la question des
produits de santé fait partie bien
évidemment clairement de ces priorités
il y a la question la question des
consommations des médicaments il y a à
la fois la pertinence des traitements il
y a la observance des traitements et
puis il y a aussi la question également
de l'explosion des épidémies sans même
parler du covid qui a aussi généré vous
le disiez tout à l'heure madame leur
rapporteur dans les éléments
multifactoriels de la pénurie il y a
aussi ça on a été confronté à des
difficultés avec un état général de
santé de la population qui a nécessité
également davantage de médicaments mais
quand même remarquons quand même que
nous sommes toujours l'un des pays les
plus consommateurs nos médicaments
anxiolytique pour être plus précis par
rapport à des pays comme les Pays-Bas la
comparaison n'a pas besoin d'être
développée beaucoup plus est-ce que
c'est l'un des éléments en partie est-ce
que ça explique la pénurie à proprement
parler non mais dans un environnement
multifactoriel oui effectivement cela
est nature et nature à jouer à jouer
beaucoup mais sur la question du
financement des stocks
une PME peut pas financer tous les
stocks
et là la question se pose quel est le
rôle de la puissance publique et pardon
quel est le rôle de la puissance
publique au niveau européen parce que si
on constitue des stocks au niveau
européen là il faut savoir ce que l'on
veut j'estime que c'est aussi au niveau
européen clairement que la question doit
se poser une PME ne pourra pas financer
des stocks ou faire le tampon comme
c'est comme c'est le cas pour un grand
labo d'où l'idée aujourd'hui de
différencier et si je peux me permettre
si je peux me permettre c'est vous-même
madame la sénatrice qu'il est qu'il
évoquait tout à l'heure je pense que sur
la question du prix aujourd'hui on a un
élastique qui se tend entre les grands
labos et les génériqueurs et au milieu
il y a les entreprises dont on parlait
tout à l'heure et là où je suis d'accord
c'est que le problème n'est pas de
financer biogaran sur des
investissements là la question je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure il y a deux leviers
d'action il y a le financement des
investissements
et on peut très bien prendre des volumes
de chiffres d'affaires ou autre ayant
ensuite la solvabilisation du marché par
les prix et une entreprise comme
biogaran s'il décidait notamment de
relocaliser c'est avec les prix sur le
marché qu'ils peuvent s'y retrouver mais
là on n'a pas besoin de faire le même
effort d'investissement que pour une PME
vous voyez si bien que ça évite d'être
logé exactement la même enseigne que les
PME dont on a besoin de redensifier
notre territoire et qui plus est ça va
intéresser beaucoup de territoires de
pouvoir justement bénéficier de cette
relocalisation dont on parle davantage
que on en envoie aujourd'hui les fruits
faut dire les choses telles faut le dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont
notamment dans le souffrance les
phénomènes qui ont été vus où sont des
phénomènes il y a encore une fois à des
grands labos c'est bien mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que pour répondre à nos
questions de pénurie aujourd'hui la clé
la clé du problème n'est pas encore
celle là donc sur les stocks ça peut pas
être des PME qui financent puissance
publique oui mais là au niveau européen
je pense que ça a du sens exige j'en
reviens à la question que vous évoquiez
je pense qu'il faut très clairement
on veut de la souveraineté industrielle
en matière pharmaceutique ok alors faut
qu'il y ait un bonus souveraineté
faut qu'il y a un bonus ouvrenté le
bonus souveraineté on le décompose aide
massive à l'investissement ou
solvabilisation du marché avec une
répartition qui peut être lié au niveau
du chiffre d'affaires pour éviter qu'il
y a un effet d'aubaine ou de double
aubaine pour certains mais clairement
c'est un bonus souveraineté qu'il faut
très clairement mettre en place et on
veut le faire si je peux me permettre
comment se fait-il que les gouvernements
n'aient pas lu à l'époque le rapport du
Sénat sur la question comment se fait-il
que les gouvernements s'émeuvent
aujourd'hui les pénuries alors même
qu'il y a une proposition de loi qui
avait été déposée si je ne me trompe pas
en août 21 par un sénateur un sénateur
j'avais pas dire des hauts trans mais un
sénateur du Nord et tout est dedans tout
est dedans pourquoi ils l'ont pas lu
pourquoi le ministère de la Santé n'a
pas lieu pas bien l'application c'était
si je me trompe pas une PPL avec très
articles c'était un rapport d'une
commission avec une trentaine de
recommandations elles ont pas pris une
ride hélas elles auraient gagné elles
auraient gagné à être rendu absolument
et opérationnel qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
attendu est-ce qu'ils ont attendu c'est
tout le problème d'ailleurs on voit bien
dans notre pays c'est qu'il y a
nombreuses solutions qui sont sur la
table empirique concrètes parce que vous
interrogez qui vous interrogez d'anciens
ministre interrogé des responsables
publics et je suis certain que vous
faites comme je faisais quand j'étais
ministre avant de préparer cette
audition vous avez interrogé des acteurs
de terrain notamment des pharmaciens qui
vous expliquent facilement les choses
qui vous expliquerai facilement les
choses et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui les leçons sont là
il y a un vrai problème d'anticipation
il y a une question de prix et ensuite
c'est si on veut clairement passer à la
phase de relocalisation et de
souveraineté est-ce qu'on met en place
oui ou non un bonus souveraineté et vers
qui on le flèche en priorité
pardon juste un point juste un point vos
motorisez ma question madame la
Présidente
Monsieur le scénario
has ansm vers qui pencherait votre
préférence
oui moi aussi non je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est parce que là on est
clairement sur une dimension
médical de chez médical le vrai problème
pourquoi est-ce qu'on multiplie les
procédures en France
pourquoi on multiplie les procédures
plus les procédures sont longues plus de
temps vous mettez admettre un médicament
remboursement et pendant ce temps-là
l'assurance maladie des bourses pas oui
le système je le dis très clairement a
été mis en place en France de telle
façon que plus vous tardez moins vous
dépensez d'argent tout de suite
un système qui malthusiani
mais pardon c'est le même problème dans
les autorisations d'établissement de
santé ou l'établissement pour personnes
âgées plus les procédures tardent moins
vous avez dépenses à fonctionner parce
qu'on n'a jamais eu le courage de dire
que clairement nous n'avions pas les
moyens de pouvoir mettre en place toutes
les politiques nécessaires et en matière
de médicaments ça a été le cas des
médicaments tarde à être admis sur le
marché à être admis au remboursement
parce que pendant ce temps-là ce sont
des mois qui sont gagnés
et le système a fonctionné comme ça
pendant bien longtemps pendant bien
longtemps certains ministres ont
accéléré des procédures peut-être pu le
reprocher des moments donnés mais c'est
aussi l'une des clés n'osent pas dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont malgré
toutes les sommes que l'on débourse
notre système de santé d'assurance
maillet est insuffisamment financée on
ne veut pas regarder suffisamment le
poids des ALD on ne peut pas voir le
vieillissement de la population le fait
que l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
diminue et aujourd'hui qu'on est
justement les pénuries de médicaments
parce qu'en matière de santé l'un des
enjeux c'est la prévention en matière
politique c'est l'anticipation
alors je reviens juste sur un point que
vous aviez évoqué tout à l'heure les
Prusse à l'époque quand il est mis en
place
j'ai Prusse quand il est mis en place ne
veuille pas se préparer uniquement à la
question justement de la pandémie
grippal sur H1N1 mais vise aussi à
pouvoir se doter mesure d'anticipation
pour constituer des socles y compris de
médicaments y compris le produit de
santé y compris de matériel notamment
sur qui permettent l'injection de
produits seringues et autres c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait que à l'époque
quand il y a eu H1
ma successeur je crois n'a manqué de
rien n'a manqué de rien mais les Prusse
a disparu un jour il a été non pas
remplacé il était fondu dans un ensemble
plus grand
sur les Prusse parce que je suis
complètement d'accord avec le président
des Hauts de France je voudrais lui dire
que dans le même temps où les Prusse a
disparu les NVS a disparu exactement
société extrêmement importante et qui
permettait avec des médecins vigilants
un peu partout sur le territoire
national d'être prévenu de ce qui
pouvait se passer et c'est à la lumière
de ce que j'avais pu vivre avec la crise
du chikungunya et de la dingue qu'on
s'était aperçu que l'InVS avait besoin
de clarifier ses missions de voir
renforcer ses prérogatives mais de
pouvoir faire cette veille stratégique
je voulais quand même rebondir sur sur
la chaîne et
la NSM et aussi la relation comment dire
au budget et à la masse budgétaire qui
est consentie par la puissance publique
pour pouvoir pour rembourser le
médicament ou le prendre en compte il y
a aussi un sujet qui qui est pas celui
de la pénurie en direct mais on voit
bien que tout ça est quand même très que
c'est finalement le budget qui contraint
le cadre puisque les autorisations de
mise sur le marché et notamment les
indications sont pas forcément les mêmes
que dans d'autres pays européens et
qu'on a tendance à avoir des des
indications moins larges pour avoir
moins d'indications remboursables pour
certaines pathologies et ça aussi c'est
un sujet qui qui est pas celui de la
pénurie mais quelque part vis-à-vis de
nos voisins européens est une forme de
pénurie puisqu'on n'a pas accès aux
médicaments remboursé dans la même
situation
de besoin thérapeutiques madame la
présidence que vous permettrait de
saisir ce que venez de dire les
Allemands ont augmenté de 50% les prix
pour les médicaments thérapeutiques
majeurs
ils l'ont fait ils l'ont fait et
médicament thérapeutique majeur ce ne
sont pas seulement les dernières
innovations
oui mais il y a aussi les caisses
pardonnez-moi il y a les caisses de
prévoyance et notamment les caisses
régionales les caisses régionales bien
évidemment mais au final ils ont
augmenté de 50%. et à partir du moment
où ils augmentent de 50% ils sont
attractifs ça ne règle pas tout mais il
y a ça quand même
je vous remercie beaucoup de cet
échangeur et de ses réponses très
fournies monsieur le ministre je avant
de lever la séance avec d'autres
éléments qui vous viennent à l'esprit
dans l'immédiat parce que c'est un sujet
l'écureuil rare la France en produit
toujours pas
non produit toujours pas excusez-moi
d'insister là dessus je suis venu
là-dessus sur la question de 2011 ça
m'avait profondément marqué en visitant
des établissements au cœur de la crise
covid vous savez quel est le besoin
essentiel on est aujourd'hui
mi-2023 l'écura on en produit toujours
pas en France ce qui veut donc dire sur
quelque chose de clé on est toujours
dépendant d'importation
même si les hôpitaux civils de Lyon en
ont fabriqué pendant la crise de la
covid en reconstituant la monographie
qui n'existait plus et en ayant donc
remis en place la recette quelque part
pour pouvoir reconstituer la fabrication
je peux rebondir encore une fois madame
la Présidente ceux qui montrent bien que
dans les situations de crise ce sont les
soignants qui ont su s'adapter et faire
tenir le système comment se fait-il que
hors crise on ne soit pas capable
d'aborder la même logique non pas pour
produire du cura mais tout simplement de
montrer que on doit tirer les
enseignements tout le problème que l'on
a dans notre pays je l'ai dit pour 2011
je l'ai dit pour la loi médicament c'est
est-ce que l'on tire vraiment les
enseignements vous vous le faites vous
vous le faites mais derrière ceux qui
ont la responsabilité exécutive ils le
font ou pas ou est-ce qu'il cède à la
dernière sirène médiatique
au dernier instantané les réseaux
sociaux
ce n'est pas à la commission d'enquête
de répondre à cette question lors de
l'audition je vous remercie beaucoup
Monsieur le fils et nous allons donc
prendre l'audition suivante au revoir
merci beaucoup